you will never win an election
you will never be able to impose
your ideological political project no eh
Spaniards are democrats and are not fools
has called fools
to 3,800,000 Spaniards
you have done it in this rostrum,
Mr..
and I don't know what it is
what those almost 4 million Spaniards think
whom you have insulted today
in this rostrum
I don't know if they think like you
that it is silly but certainly what they do think
is that it is
in about Vox
has told you so many things today and so many things are said to you
there are still more stupid Spaniards than you think.
but people will see that we don't even bite
we have neither tail nor horn
and that we defend the general interest
which you have not done with your allies during the past 4 years.